Seit rund einem Jahr gibt es in Großbritannien
eine Ministerin für Einsamkeit.
Und auch in Deutschland wurde über die Einführung
eines solchen politischen Amtes nachgedacht.
Damit sollen Leben gerettet werden, denn Studien
zufolge ist Einsamkeit nicht nur ähnlich
gesundheitsschädigend wie Kette zu rauchen;
manche Fachleute bezeichnen sie sogar als
eine “Epidemie”.
Und es sind längst nicht nur mehr alte und
alleinstehende Menschen von diesem Problem
betroffen.
Doch was passiert eigentlich im menschlichen
Körper, wenn wir einsam sind?
Welche Wege führen aus der Einsamkeit heraus?
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich spannende Sciencevideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. herzlich willkommen!
Auf der einen Seite, wünschen sich Viele
von uns, ab und an mal einsam zu sein.
Einfach mal zur Ruhe kommen und die Sinne
schärfen… Doch auf der anderen Seite haben
viele Menschen auch extrem unter Einsamkeit
zu leiden.
Laut wissenschaftlichen Studien ist jeder
siebte Mensch einsam.
Und das bleibt nicht ohne Folgen.
Einsamkeit wurde bereits in vielen wissenschaftlichen
Studien untersucht und die Ergebnisse sind
erschreckend.
Menschen, die sich chronisch einsam fühlen,
haben demnach eine erhöhte Chance, einen
Schlaganfall, Herzinfarkt oder eine Krebserkrankung
zu bekommen.
Anders auf den Punkt gebracht: Einsamkeit
ist so ungesund wie das Rauchen von 15 Zigaretten
pro Tag.
Doch wie können Forschungsteams herausfinden,
ob Menschen wirklich einsam sind?
Viel zu einfach wäre es, dies allein an der
Intensität und Menge der Sozialkontakte auszumachen.
Denn nicht alle fühlen sich einsam, nur,
weil sie öfter mal alleine sind.
Auf der anderen Seite können sich Menschen
einsam und unverstanden fühlen, obwohl sie
viele Kontakte in den Sozialen Medien haben
und auch im realen Leben einige Bekanntschaften
haben.
Entscheidend ist das subjektive Empfinden:
Wünscht man sich mehr Gemeinschaft mit anderen
Menschen?
Leidet man unter zu wenig Kontakt und gibt
es vertraute Menschen, mit denen man persönliche
Dinge besprechen kann?
Bei Menschen, die bei dem Ausfüllen eines
solchen Fragebogens hohe Werte erreichen,
sind körperliche Veränderungen messbar.
Der US-Sozialpsychologe John Cacioppo konnte
beispielsweise nachweisen, dass bei sozial
isolierten Menschen ein erhöhter Widerstand
der Blutgefäße vorhanden ist.
Ein Faktor, der die Anfälligkeit für Bluthochdruck
erhöht.
Auch das Level des Stresshormons Cortisol
war bei einsamen Menschen deutlich erhöht.
Das bestätigen auch die Ergebnisse eines
weiteren Forschungsteams.
Die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
aus den USA hatten herausgefunden, dass Einsamkeit
zu einer Art Stresshormon-Schub führen kann.
Erwachsene, die sich Abends beim Schlafengehen
einsam und traurig gefühlt haben, zeigten
am nächsten Tag einen erhöhten Pegel des
Stresshormons.
Cortisol wird mit Krankheiten wie Fettleibigkeit
oder Depression in Zusammenhang gebracht.
Fest steht jedenfalls: Ein lang andauernder
hoher Cortisonspiegel aus dem im Körper Cortisol
entsteht, ist nicht gut für unsere Gesundheit.
Unser Immunsystem wird heruntergefahren, wir
schlafen schlechter und Blutdruck und Blutzucker
steigen an.
Zusammengefasst kann man also davon ausgehen,
dass chronische Einsamkeit einen Einfluss
auf unser sogenanntes sympathisches Nervensystem
hat und dieses aktiviert wird.
Der menschliche Körper wird damit auf eine
drohende Herausforderung vorbereitet.
Ein Notfallprogramm also und die Frage: Flucht
oder ein Kampf steht im Raum?!
Laut Cacioppo ein äußerst sinnvoller Prozess,
denn ein sozial isolierter Mensch kann nicht
auf den Schutz der Gruppe hoffen, der evolutionsbiologisch
gesehen als überlebenswichtig galt.
Denn in der Prähistorie schützte das Zusammenleben
in kleinen Gruppen vor wilden Tieren und hatte
weitere viele Vorteile.
Doch damit nicht genug: Der Forscher hat zudem
auch herausgefunden, dass bei Menschen, die
in hohem Maße einsam sind, auch die Gene
beeinflusst werden.
Konkret war die Aktivität derjenigen Gene
erhöht, die Entzündungen fördern.
In einem weiteren Experiment zeigte der Einsamkeitsforscher
Cacioppo Probanden, die unter einen Hirnscanner
lagen, Fotos von lächelnden Menschen.
Das Ergebnis war verblüffend: Im Gehirn der
derjenigen Versuchsteilnehmer, die sich selbst
als einsamer bezeichnet hatten, zeigte sich
dabei weniger Aktivität.
Ein Indiz dafür, dass sie sich über einen
solchen freundlichen Kontakt weniger freuen.
Der Hirnscan zeigte noch ein weiteres Ergebnis:
Und zwar war auch die Übergangszone zwischen
Scheitel- und Schläfenlappen weniger aktiv.
Diese Hirnregion wird mit der Fähigkeit in
Zusammenhang gebracht, sich in andere Menschen
hineinversetzen zu können.
Heißt das also, dass das Gehirn von einsamen
Menschen so strukturiert ist, dass sie von
der Nähe andere Menschen weniger profitieren
und sich auch deswegen zurückziehen?
Fest steht also: Einsamkeit kann uns krank
machen.
Doch die gute Nachricht: Wir können diesen
Gefühlen von Einsamkeit entgegensteuern und
unserem Körper beim Kampf gegen die Einsamkeit
helfen.
Und das geht ganz easy: Einfach mal wieder
jemanden in den Arm nehmen.
Dann setzt unser Körper nämlich das Hormon
Oxytocin frei.
Das wird oft auch als “Bindungshormon”
bezeichnet und aktiviert unser Belohnungssystem.
Wir fühlen uns gut und es stärkt gleichzeitig
auch unsere sozialen Bindungen.
Und noch etwas Positives kann ich Euch mit
auf den Weg geben: Im Gegensatz zum Rauchen
beispielsweise hat Einsamkeit keine langwierigen
Nachwirkungen auf unseren Körper.
Ein paar nette Bekanntschaften oder Freunde
haben haben einen total positiven Einfluss
auf unsere Gesundheit!
Also los geht’s!
Kontakte sind ja echt richtig.
Ich will deswegen mal wieder ein Communitytreffen
dieses Mal in Berlin machen.
Wer Lust dazu hat.
Schreibt es mir in die Kommentare oder schickt
mir eine persönliche Nachricht auf WhatsApp.
Dafür hier klicken!
Und ich such’ mir jetzt auch mal jemanden
zum knuddeln.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!